get into it the first one they give us
12 feet per second so what you want to
do is start with 12 feet per means
divided by so 12 feet divided by one
second but we want to convert the feet
okay into miles so what you want to do
is you want to memorize some of these
basic conversions but there's 5,280 feet
okay for every one mile now why did I
write the miles in the numerator and the
feet in the denominator well you want to
do it this way because you want the feet
in the denominator to cancel with the
feet in the numerator remember when
you're reducing fractions you can reduce
top and bottom or on the diagonal when
you're multiplying top and bottom this
way we end up with the unit's we want
which are miles now we just need to
convert the seconds to hours right so we
know that there's 60 seconds in a minute
right so 60 seconds for every one minute
and so you can see the seconds are
canceling numerator in the denominator
we're left with minutes but we want
hours right so we have to convert those
minutes now by saying there's 60 minutes
in one hour so you can see the minutes
cancel numerator and denominator and you
can see we're left with miles in the
numerator hours in the denominator
that's miles per hour now you might be
wondering you know Mario why does this
work well when you're multiplying by one
mile over 5,280 feet one mile is equal
to 5,280 feet anything divided by itself
is one right when you multiply by one it
doesn't change the value of this initial
quantity all it does is it changes the
units so we're not changing anything
we're just changing the unit's okay so
it's the same same you know rate
basically feet per second so then what
you would do is you would multiply all
the numerators together you'd multiply
all the denominators together you'd have
a numerator divided by a denominator you
would divide those and you get your
answer now I solve these before I did
this video lesson here for you guys and
this is came out to about 8.2 miles per
hour so it's about 8.2 miles per hour